[Aplausos]
[Música]
recibidos como Héroes los soldados
ucranianos entraron en la Plaza de la
libertad de gerson en medio de aplausos
de quienes celebran La retirada del
ejército ruso de la única capital
regional que Moscú había tomado desde el
inicio de la guerra
este viernes Rusia aseguró haber
concluido de forma total su retirada y
Ucrania celebra la retoma del control de
una ciudad estratégica la ciudad de
gerson se encuentra en su etapa final
hay mucho trabajo para limpiar el área
desminar la ciudad tenemos entendido que
los ocupantes antes de irse hicieron
estallar la planta de energía térmica de
gerson estación de distribución de la
compañía de energía de la región junto a
la torre de televisión destruyeron parte
electrónica de la misma Tendremos que
restaurarlo todo para el kremlin el
repliegue no cambia el estatus quo
asegurando que no hubo bajas en sus
tropas y que no dejaron atrás ni una
sola pieza de armamento gerson es un
tema de la federación rusa está
legalmente fijado y definido no hay
cambios y no puede haber cambios sin
embargo según las autoridades ucranianas
varios soldados rusos terminaron
ahogados tratando de salir de la urbe y
varios de Ellos están en posiciones
fortificadas que construyeron
recientemente del otro lado del río
nieper los medios ucranianos informaron
que el único punto de paso entre la
ciudad de gerson y la otra orilla del
río nieper el de antonovsky había
colapsado el cruce más cercano a 70
kilómetros y aledaño a Novak hofka
también está en medio de tensiones Pues
de ambas partes se acusan de atacar una
Represa clave que de romperse generaría
un caudal que arrasaría con poblaciones
enteras e inundaría